doing this now because I know this will
maybe upset you a little bit to save you
an entire lifetime of to quote Sam
Kinison hey Steven I'm really stuck and
need some help okay before I continue if
you're physically stuck like in the bago
dorm stench if it's quicksand you know I
cannot help you man in fact the rest of
letters empty so what if what if the guy
you cut happened had to cook them had to
cut his arm off he was stuck between the
right oh oh when he goes through the
ulnar nerve ooh that's really rough to
watch I didn't watch it on purpose okay
stuck need to bail for the past month or
so I've been going out with this girl a
lot of relationship advice a lot of
people I've noticed in the me to era
that that's just become a lot I'm more
prevalent I'm starting to get really
strong feelings and then want everything
to go well but there seems to be one
thing wrong she's a Democrat what do you
think my advice what do you think my
advice is going to be yeah
by the way Democrat look Capital D not a
lowercase D it's that much of a problem
really she's already got into you not
only that but I'm afraid she may be a
leftist well she's a Democrat of course
yeah I mean it doesn't seem to be if
she's going this is what I always don't
love how Democrats are sell I'm a
classical liberal what do you mean I
believe in freedom except for taxes
abortion and all right so I believe in
freedom just not economic freedom you
know freedom to pick your own health
care for him to pick your own retirement
plan on me but I'm awful look I want you
to be able to say offensive things and
I'm only able to do weird sex tricks I'm
a classical liberal but I want to take
your money at gunpoint you got a classic
liberal shut up no get away all right
she's going to go for local science and
and then later law school is it possible
for me to have a meaningful discussion
with her and be able to defend the views
that I see is moral unfair or should I
just keep my mouth shut and avoid it
like the plague missed an e on the law
this is tough love I'm your guru you
like the spellcheck you do not know how
to spell the word da you have no chance
in life it's got an A on the Indigo
she's a Democrat she's probably a bit
know what's going on you just keep my
mouth shut half my family Democrat but
not nearly this degree
really worried that when she talks down
to me I'll loose I'll lose interest in
her and Wang to move on I think this was
written on an iPhone this Wang by the
way if it autocorrected wants to Wang I
would like to see your texture this lady
how many times have you said Wang yeah
her how many pictures have been sent oh
wow
plot it also views okay that means
political views okay isn't something I
think people need to take into
consideration when deciding who to marry
okay
I have no advice for you you're an idiot
you are an idiot I I'm sorry listen I
prefer stof this is like what I used to
watch I used to listen dr. Laura as a
kid and some would call in and go
denture Laura I love your show a long
time listener first up he says I get
really good BJ's and she's like oh okay
so literal or that's what she used to
say here you have seen this show I first
off a couple of things um there seems to
be one thing wrong she's a Democrat
that's the ultimate wrong you know
Democrat leftist you go on to specify
love is it possible for me to have
meaningful discussion no should I be
should I just keep my mouth shut what
are you it doesn't are you a man can you
can you do a testicular check for me
right now do it as though you're
checking for a firm chest you know what
let's go with prostate cancer as well I
want a deep and thorough exam because if
you are even thinking about marrying
someone who will talk down to you and
makes you it makes you think that you
might have to keep your mouth shut and
you're talking about marriage that means
keep your mouth shut and have someone
talk down to you for the rest of your
life what are you out of your mind sir I
don't think it matters well guess what
it does it does matter it does matter
her political views matter her religious
views matter what she sees as moral
immoral it's the only thing that matters
dummy what do you think it's matter
where she has c-cups
he's probably not a boob guy my probably
like the same movies we have the same
shut up go ahead this is the part where
exactly guys go after the wrong things
he contradicts himself he
through the pains of writing you a
letter and then says none of the things
that he's brought up as concerns matter
in dating I don't really understand I
don't think the problem is the the girl
I think he's the problem he is a logical
contradiction of himself these things
the two most important conversations you
can ever have politics and religion
those two things are the most important
you never shut up on those things and
yes they're important he already knows
that because you wrote the letter right
I'm not sure where he's coming from now
people say don't talk about those two
things like I understand maybe if you're
in a barber shop no have comedy I still
have a say but it certainly doesn't
apply to your future spouse right in the
half of the family that's Democrat so
you can't keep your mouth shut for
everyone's what are you gonna do when
you're raising is Atlanta fuss yeah what
do you when you're three-year-olds are
getting taken kids out of their power
wheels and punching them in the face
look that's a practical thing so I was
in a relationship the other girl that I
almost married when I was in my early
20s we had this thing and I came down to
it she didn't believe in God and she was
a super left-leaning person and I was
just just infatuated with this girl and
finally one of my buddies thank god said
what are you doing you're never gonna be
able to like think down the road when
you have it me no it wasn't you yeah
I've been that quite a few times now the
writer gave me some good tough love
along the way here he said you know I
did you know I love you yes it was very
helpful helpful advice but he did the
same thing like and you can't just think
that these things aren't important and
won't affect life decisions man is I
would disagree with you he's not you're
not a walking logical contradiction
you're a spineless person I mean this
right now
you're a spite now why am I being so I'm
being harsh here because first off with
love for with love why I'm doing this
now because I know this will maybe upset
you a little bit to save you an entire
lifetime of to quote Sam Kinison so
right now a little bit oh that stings as
opposed to 30 40 50 years of the
faithful wounds of a friend copper
doesn't even care it's just so rude and
by the way to all the people who were
asking okay it's real sleepy I would
give this same advice to some if an aunt
if a person said should I marry a
Lindsay Graham first off I'd say there's
an issue here second no I'm sorry I
don't I just don't agree with it I don't
think you should marry someone I don't
think you should waste
a relationship with someone who has a
fundamentally different view of the
world than you do especially if you're
talking about bringing children into the
equation oh my god that would get very
difficult very fast now at one point of
clarification here if you don't really
care about what's going on and you just
check the boxes are and they check the
boxes D and then there's different right
it wouldn't bother you in the first
place we're talking about people that
have big beliefs in these camps I okay
let me ask you a question here's here's
the the Guru asking you a question if
you don't think it matters you don't
think the morality matters you don't
think a role view matters you don't
think politics matter look it seems the
world does in a different way than I do
I seems maybe I'm in the minority okay
comment I'd like to hear it I'd like to
hear your advice your feedback how do
you pick a spouse yeah what does matter
what does matter because you know what
for those people I don't have any advice
I really don't to me these are the first
questions you've got to ask
I just just said it you sending an email
in here to a segment called tough tough
love I do not it isn't something I think
people need to take into consideration
when deciding who to marry first Furion
says you don't even say like I don't
think it's a deal breaker I don't think
it's something people need to take into
consideration when it comes to who
you're married you need to take
everything into consideration right yeah
yeah include including where your hips
are in relation to your body what kind
of torque that will generate your puzzle
pieces man emotionally spiritually
physically everything matters and you're
saying everything matters except what
should what should be at the base of the
food pyramid which we were told for a
long time was life cereal right which
led to the base of your pyramid takeoff
that's all gone yeah this is this is
this is moronic if you believe this it's
moronic but I don't think you believe it
because it wouldn't be bothering you and
you wouldn't be emailing me asking for
advice run this video watch another one
of our videos or subscribe it's a
notification bell those don't really
mean anything anymore today in YouTube I
would say hit a like was a thumbs up but
that might be gone or comment below but
that most likely will be censored so
bookmark the page of course if you're
using Google Chrome they'll find a way
to [ __ ] with your bookmark so just join
up at Lara's credit
slash mug Club that's a lot of us credit
outcome slash mug Club you get a hand at
schmuck and you get access to the fall
daily one-hour show and you're not
beholden to Susan Wojcicki slash Clint
Howard